I am not trying to throw any shade at all
I just feel like this needs to be talked about
cause I don't see it being talked about anywhere
the people that are taking these hormones and doing these things
to transition to other genders
whether it's a man or a woman
when you're taking drugs to shut down the natural production of your hormones
that your specific gender
your physiologic design is meant to produce
because men and women have to
totally different biological and physiologic designs
and hormonal structures
and when you forcibly shut that down and then take synthetic hormones instead
you're enacting war on your body
like full blown enacting war on your body
and you can see it you see it in how rapidly these people age and like it
the same goes for women that are doing all cause
like people that are transitioning
and a lot of women are getting the same procedures done
ah injections um
hormone replacement to be birth control too
because birth control also shuts down the natural production of your hormones
and replaces it when with synthetic ones
that are actually proven to cause cancer
autoimmunity
all kinds of very detrimental things to your health and physiologic design
but like when you get all these things injected
you get all these procedures done
you get implants that are foreign objects in your body again
like even that
aside from the hormone like
replacing your endocrine systems natural
um
part in the ecosystem that is your body
because you are an entire ecosystem
every single component has a very important role
to play in the balance and flow of your entire system
when that falls out of balance or you actually remove an entire piece
like your endocrine system is a very important aspect to your body's function
and so when you shut that down and then replace it with chemicals
synthetic chemicals um
you're causing a lot of health issues
and I don't see that aspect being talked about
like all the moral and philosophical ideology and opposing views and whatever
put that aside and let's just talk about the health component
and how destructive it is to your body
and how unnatural it is and how hard it is on your body
and then what that subsequently does
not just like the dysphoria or like
whatever mental illness is associated with that shift
but just the health aspect
like
we already know that birth control and hormone replacement causes depression
and increase like 80% up like
increase in an uptick of being prescribed antidepressants and adolescents
like there's so much research and data
that already shows how destructive replacing these hormones are in the body
and then you add in
the mental illness component of like
feeling like you're in the wrong body
like never do we ever affirm that in someone who has like
body dysmorphia with you know
they think they're fat but they're actually like
terribly skinny and like
a really unhealthy depleted state of malnutrition
the same goes here like
it totally goes here too
and it's I'm just gonna say like
it's impossible for someone that's doing this to their body
to be healthy and to be in a healthy state of mind
because of how unnatural and against nature it goes
whether you think it's right or wrong
or whether you think that it's normal or okay to be born in the wrong body
a we're not talking about the health repercussions
nor are we asking why no one's asking why this happens
people therapist
everyone's just going Whoo
and then conversy on the other two
people were just going like
it's unnatural it's against god
I'm on the side with god
but I'm also on the side of like
we need to give them help
gender affirming care is not help
it's not help it's actually like
both sides are completely missing a really important component
in my opinion which is
why are you this way and what can we do to support you in the root cause of why
I totally believe that societal conditioning is
is a giant role to play like
we shouldn't be telling people that
like little boys and people that are dressing up as girls
like we shouldn't just jump to be like
oh my gosh
you must be a girl
no like
it's okay to like
want to dress up in other clothes
or whatever parental um
guidance you think there was
or lack thereof like
whatever you wanna call it
like
saying that like
just affirming that you were born in the wrong body is not help
that is not care that is not health care
that is actually that should be like
illegal if I'm being completely honest with you
because I know so many people that were like abused as children
smexually
verbally physically
there are so many times where you don't wanna be in your body as children
as a woman there are so many times where our circumstances
make us not wanna be us
right
that's why people end their lives
that's why people run away
that's why people dress or dye their armpit hair
or cuddle their hair off or um
harden their shell
there's so many symptoms
and so many areas where it's so blatantly clear that people are just hurting
it doesn't mean that we need to run away from this body
that is just a symptom that dissociation
I grew up in so much trauma
smexual trauma like
as a child abandonment
betrayal death um
not feeling safe there are so many times where I felt like I didn't wanna be me
and like
it wasn't safe to be me
and I've seen so many children and women that are the product
and men too little boys
as well that are products of trauma and not feeling safe
and I feel like it's a cry to feel safe
to finally feel belonging to finally feel
in control
so I just wanna go why not
it's wrong you're the devil
like that's not help
and that's not the answer
I understand that we're in a war of good versus evil
light versus dark god versus the devil
like I'm not questioning that
that is so evident in so many components of our
of our lives right now in the media
in the way the governments ran
in social media in
the news like
there's so many areas where it's so clear that it's good versus evil
but the division is how we're controlled
it's there's so much great area
there's so much nuance and it's so unfair and such an injustice to just be like
you're just evil you have to ask why
why is this happening that's just because conditioning does
to predators child predators trauma
societal conditioning and then we have to go
how do we fix this
how do we support the people that feel like they're in the wrong body
don't just affirm them don't just applaud them
don't just hand them drugs and surgery on a silver platter
that's not care
no
and neither is telling them that they are like
against the Bible and against god
neither of those offer a real solution
to see them and to validate them
and to meet them where they're at
and offer them the support that they actually need